somebody told me yesterday that rich
hickey
said that i should give him my slides
and he could talk the talk for me
which are you here don't see him so
i have to give the talk then so you'll
see my version of it
trouble with types so
well types are ubiquitous everybody has
an opinion on them
and it seems like it's one of the most
contentious issues in programming
languages
people love them and can't do without
them or they hate hate them and think
well
any language with types is just too too
hard to complicate it
there's also interestingly and split in
between industry and academia here
industry
of course used to be very much
statically typed
there was c there was pascal
and c plus java all languages with
static type systems
and only over the last decade or 15
years or so
dynamically typed languages called up
the lisps the closures the rubies pearls
pythons and so on if you look at let's
say the emerging languages symposium
that we had
on the day before strange loop and i
guess almost
all of the presentations here were about
dynamically typed languages
on academia on the other hand if you go
to icfp the conference on functional
programming next week in boston
you will find almost every talk is about
types in one form or another
so about languages with types or about
type systems
things like that so academia these days
is much more type
oriented than industry
but the debate between static and
dynamic
of course i don't really want to rehash
it i don't just we can
go endlessly through points i just have
listed the five main points for each
sides
that you say for static type systems i
guess the main argument
originally was they're more efficient
still are
there's better tooling you can write
ides for them that do
command completion hyperlinking find
references
refactoring all these things work better
with static types
you don't need as many tests because
some parts of the
your program properties are already
checked by the type checker there's
better documentation
because types are documentation which
can never get out of sync
so unlike comments a type always tells
the truth about the program
as long as the program compiles and i
believe
from a practical perspective types are
most useful when it comes to program
maintenance
if you have to refactor or maintain a
program that somebody else
wrote there can be an incredibly safety
net whereas uh
with tests uh tests are the feedback
cycle is just too
slow you do a refactoring you run your
tests uh
15 minutes later some tests fail you
have to sort of get back to the point
where why do they fail and things like
that whereas types give you immediate
feedback
and also much more informative feedback
on the for dynamically typed languages
there are also a lot of points in favor
i think the main important one from for
from my perspective is
they tend to be a lot simpler types
add incredibly to the to the footprint
of a language
because essentially that's the system
that tells you gives you some
assurances about properties that the
program will have and that's generally a
very complicated things
the other advantage i guess in
particular for teaching languages is
there are fewer puzzling compiler errors
types catch errors early
that's good but sometimes the errors
that you get are
very hard to actually wrap your head
around and understand and
sometimes people would actually prefer
to just say well let just let it crash
let it crash at runtime and let me
figure out what what what
went wrong in a debugger uh there's no
boilerplate
types often add quite considerably to
the
number of letters you have to write
characters you have to write in your
program
and they're generally much easier for
exploration because well with a
without without static types you can
leave off parts of your program
and run what you have and well if you
fall down a cliff with a
you get a method not found error but
that's not the end of the world right
and finally the the fifth uh argument
was
well type systems limit the
expressiveness of
programmers if i want to as a programmer
i want to express myself
the way i believe is right for the
program and types
only get in the way for that that of
course depends on
the kind of type system you have so
these are the points
in favor against and we can argue the
whole talk but i guess it would be
rather boring
so i want to talk about something else i
want to talk about what's good
design because after all as
programmers as software developers we're
all
designers and design is essentially what
we the interesting parts of our
profession
so what is a good design well there's
some properties
a good design should be clear could be
correct obviously
should be minimal it shouldn't there
shouldn't be any redundant extraneous
pieces to it
in a sense it should be the opposite of
random like if you just
throw some parts together randomly
that's not good design so good design is
obviously the
opposite of what what random is and
one thing that i for me goes to the core
of things here is something that
i learned from guy steele he told me
once that actually he thinks they
discovered
scheme they didn't invent it so i think
good designs are
discovered they're not invented this
and i believe that that leads to the
elements of great designs which
are patterns and constraints so you
build a good design from patterns it's
not random
you have patterns and you're led to it
by constraints that you impose on
yourself
if you don't have the constraints then
you fall back into randomness
and it's uh the it becomes interesting
when you essentially can
choose what your constraints are and
develop a great design
out of that so an example here
that from the world of music which i had
to play is the
fugues of bach and i'll just try to play
it
rather than talking about it let's see
whether that works out
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
oh that
[Music]
i could listen for the rest of my talk
to it but
i can't i have some other points to make
so i have to cut it here
so what you saw here and i think this an
animation was actually quite good you
saw the patterns and these fugues
these repeating patterns and how they
are composed and i think
if the fugues are great because bach
chose some constraints
uh he chose a melody and says well let's
vary this this melody and not
take anything else which is random okay
so what's a language for good design
then well
obviously one that helps discovering
great designs that's what we're after
and that means that
we want to have patterns and patterns in
programming are
best kept with abstractions so we need
powerful abstraction capabilities that's
what programming is about
and we want constraints and there are
very variety to express the constraints
but one good way i believe is types
types are an excellent way
to express constraints to constrain
ourselves
how we program a piece of a program a
library a software system
an application so a good example from
programming
i believe at least for me is functional
collections and
generalizations for instance monarchs
applicatives and so on
where if you program with functional
collections then
you're also more or less led to a great
design
and if your language is typed like if
haskellers or scala is or
a camel is then you
i'm sure you have also had this
experience that you write a program with
500 lines of code using this style
and while you have type errors you fix
them but afterwards it runs
it's correct from the start and i'm not
that good a programmer i never had that
experience with any any other language
before so i really need the types
to get there so you saw that the
constraints led
directly to a great design a good design
and also correct design
powerful patterns made safe by types
but so that was the pro argument
counter argument is type systems are
hairy
otherwise there wouldn't be so many
different of them and here
i have to quote ellen k who said i'm not
against types but i don't know of any
type systems that aren't a complete pain
so i still like dynamic typing that's a
good point as well so
if we look at what kind of type systems
are there then
one ontogoly on ontology that you often
see is between
static and dynamic types and weak and
strong types
and if you populate that square here a
little bit then
assembly language would be dynamically
typed and it would be very weak
could do anything and there would be all
the strong statically typed languages
like ruby python closure
static and weak would be c that's the
prototypical example here
and then the other languages on static
and strong you have
typically the ocamo haskell
a bit less strong and a bit less static
is java and c-sharp
why a bit less static well first we have
casts and then you have this problem
with array unsoundness that actually
some of the
things you have to some of the type
errors you can catch only at runtime
arrays need to contain a runtime type
tag
and catch you out in there more about
that later
and then some of the later languages in
particular javascript world actually
become a little bit weaker and a little
bit more dynamic even
with optional type systems i like dart
or types sort of retrofitted to
javascript like typescript
but if we for the moment forget
about the dynamic and static dimension
and concentrate only on static type
systems then i think i can
have another distinction of two
dimensions and that's we have weak and
strong as before
and we have coarse and detailed so now
i'm talking about how precise are my
types
how many of them are there how precise
can i model things
and there that's quite interesting we
have also several quadrants
and they have completely different
philosophy to type systems
so let me try to distinguish those a
little bit
we have the lower right quadrant which
somewhat teasingly i call my way or the
highway
or you could also say one way to do it
and sometimes no way to do it
that would be the the
sort of simple typesis type languages
the prototypical example was java
up to generics so java4 and a more
modern example is go
which is a very nicely put together
language but which firmly is in this
philosophy
uh to say well we give you only very
simple types
there are some types that you can use
generically such as
channels or arrays for the others you
can't add any new ones if you want any
new of generic types in your program
you're out of luck use another language
the other one would be the sort of the
classical
type systems has developed a lot in
academia which i call here type it to
the max
so essentially types are the salvation
of
almost everything there's haskell or
camel
scala f sharp in that quadrant and the
last one is sort of the postmodern type
systems
i would call it uh which
say well it's okay to cut corners uh
don't don't bother about
correctness too much let's just cut some
corners and
people will will be happy so here the
modern examples are
typescript and dart of course now i've
i've only
mentioned except for c languages that
sort of
uh became popular in the last decade or
so
uh last 15 years so there are of course
also some also some
goes back much further than that so in
the cutting corners we have a famous
example that's isil which has
essentially very much the same
philosophy here
and in the uh my way of the highway exam
you have essentially the pascal
languages which are also in the same
philosophy which that's why we have
uh very strong type systems but uh
there's only a very limited way you can
express yourself in them
okay so that's the landscape of static
type systems
c-sharp and java they're sort of in the
middle they're quite good
compromise languages maybe that's why
they're so popular
so let's look at the things and discuss
and criticize
the the parts here in a bit more detail
my way or the highway
so languages like java pre-generics
have very simple type systems no
generics or generics limited
more precisely to just a set of standard
types in the case of java 4 that was
just the array the array was generic
the rest wasn't and
consequently they were not very
extensible by users
so you picked uh the language
abstractions that were given to you and
that's all you could do
that's actually not bad so that that we
probably as programmers where a lot
people here are power programmers they
would hate that
but in fact that it has very very
important advantages and maybe these
advantages
are precisely why languages like the
original java
go are very very successful
the first one is simpler tooling if you
don't have a complex type checker you
can write a much much
simpler compiler faster compiler too and
the second one is
it's highly normative in a language like
pre-generic java there's basically one
way to do things
and then you read stuff like you say
java is great because
i can read the java code written by
anybody else and they can
understand it immediately but why is
that well because everybody writes the
same java and why is that
well because you don't have
fundamentally another way to express
yourself you don't have another way
to create new abstractions now java of
course now has generics
and but i think the philosophy has
lasted a little bit and generics and
java are also
not that easy to use and not that easy
to write good libraries for and
therefore
it has sort of kept on a little bit this
idea
but i believe in the this idea to have
normative languages
where you say well essentially the
language designers did the job of design
for you
design is done now you apply it has
definitely a lot of advantages in a lot
of situations because
you don't will not have the fear that
your co-worker will come up with a
design that i find great but you find
totally inscrutable so that's the
advantage
the second quadrant was type it to the
max so that's like the languages
haskell of camel scala f-sharp
so they have typically very rich
languages to write types
often these languages are even too
incomplete so you can do anything in
there
they have powerful type combination
forms including of course generics often
several others and the type systems
there are often inspired by logic so
they have
type systems that have a very good
foundation in logic
and therefore modulo bugs are considered
correct
these languages i think they try to
address the concerns raised by dynamic
languages head-on so where are the
advantages of dynamic languages
well no type imposed limits to
expressiveness
well with these languages we have a very
rich type system
so we can actually model usually these
things
quite well with types and furthermore if
we add some
small escape patches such as casts or
annotations of unchecked variants in
scala things like that
you can actually get around that that
you say well if
actually i want to break out the
constraints imposed by my type system i
can do that
i just have to do it explicitly but
being explicit typically
is a good thing no no boilerplate well
uh there's this type inference for that
that means that at least reduces
boilerplate a lot and easier for
operation for exploration
uh at least in scala we have uh
quite useful tools for that so there's a
bottom type nothing
which is a subtype of any other type so
it's essentially the
type that is the can fit any other
demand
and there's a value of that which is
written triple question mark and that
just means unimplemented
this function will return nothing
because i haven't implemented yet
so what i can write in scala for
instance is a function like that
def x end equals triple question mark
and it says well i don't know
i haven't implemented that yet but you
can use it already of course
so you can write code that uses that
function and well if you call it you
will get a
not implemented exception and i can also
use this triple question mark in
expressions like if i have an if then
else
and as i don't know what to do for the
case where x is less than zero yet
let me do something else and come back
to that you can also put this anywhere
these purple question marks and it will
always be type correct because nothing
is the bottom type
it fits any type constraint
okay so that addressed three points of
dynamically typed languages what about
the other two
well there the situation is
unfortunately not that good
simpler languages well rich types do
add a lot of complexity i guess they are
at least when i can speak in scholars
most of the complexity in scala
comes from the types otherwise scala is
a fairly simple language
it has fairly few constructs but the
types definitely
are complex fewer puzzling compiler
errors
what about that
yeah i have to own up to that so that's
also
there's progress that's progress here so
that's scalar 210
and you get this and another 200 lines
if you tried the same thing in 2-8 the
compiler would actually
uh i don't know whether it looped
forever or tried to prepare the output
message forever i didn't have the
patience to wait
so that's progress and i should also say
these things
are considered bugs so these are things
in the ticket database so so it's got a
ticket database so if somebody
figures that out that they almost
certainly will file a bug so
it will not happen that often but it can
happen
and that's the problem with these
languages so we're going to get to that
in the end
a little bit but and what fundamentally
what happened here was
that the type checker was trying to
combine
to compute the the join the least upper
bound of two types
and that join didn't exist in a simple
form
so it got approximated by this monster
here
so that's the problem that essentially
there was a in the computation there's
some
things because we're dealing with a very
powerful language there's some things
where
things explode if you write a program
then also sometimes you get a stack
trace that explodes so it's very hard to
write programs that under
all circumstances can give you something
that is small and reasonable
and that's a challenge for type systems
here
need a type debugger for that that's
actually a pretty promising uh avenue to
say
well in dynamically typed languages if
all you would get
in a runtime era that you would
get a program terminated near line
370 you wouldn't be very happy you would
say i need types i can't deal with the
errors here
but of course you get so much more than
that you get a debugger you can
immediately inspect where you came from
what the value of your
variables is and so on so for types we
have we are sort of
in type systems the classic mode is
that's precisely what you get you get a
single line or a couple of lines
of type errors so it would be actually
quite interesting to see can we do more
can we explore it but it's not trivial
either because here
what you actually need to explore is
sort of the combination of a program
that you don't know that's a type
checker
and it's input that's your program so
this is sort of a level harder
than just debug a single program okay
so that's sort of the trouble with
typing to the max i think
both the upsides and the downsides
what about the last one cutting corners
the post-modern languages
so what they say is let's appeal to a
user's intuition
and one of these intuitions very strong
is that you say generics is always
should always be covariant so that means
that if i have let's say
an array of apples then that should be
also an array of fruit of course
well here's another thing that these
languages would tell you
employees are persons so functions from
employees to employers
are also functions from persons to
employers because functions are generic
and well it's covariant employee to
employer
employee is a subtype of person so
employee to employer is a subtype of
person to employer
right now
no way i mean an employee as an employer
a person doesn't necessarily have an
employer if it's a child
what's the employer of a child so
clearly that would be a function that
would go wrong
in a large part of its input it would be
the wrong type
or otherwise put it would be the wrong
type relationship
so these languages embrace unsoundness
and say well it doesn't matter
people think like that so let's just
cater to that well
one problem here i think is that it's
probably true that
it's for many programmers at the present
stage
audience excluded of course is that
programmers have a hard time wrapping
the head around functions
functions are a higher level concept
this is difficult
but if you start having type systems of
that that's the best way to make sure
that it will stay like that
right that's just to give them
essentially rules that are wrong in
these things and to say well yeah
use this so these languages are
easy and they're superficially simple to
pick up
the words from real cheeky here but i
think in
underlying they're anything but so i
think fundamentally
it's a hack and the provocative question
here can we build
great designs on theories that are
fundamentally false
that's essentially the question that we
have to pose ourselves here
so i've picked up three
important aspects that we want from
types we want them to be precise we want
them to be
sound we want them to be simple take any
two
type it to the maxwell sound and precise
but
not really simple my way or the highway
were
sound and simple but not very precise
these others are precise and
well maybe easy not exactly simple but
not sound well
i wouldn't be here if i wasn't an
optimist and saying well we can make
progress so let me
show you in the second part of the talk
how we might go about
doing that so
let's look at abstractions first so
there are two fundamental forms
the parameters and these are positional
and they typically come from the
functional world
and they're abstract members so abstract
members
are name-based that means you have
an abstract method and abstract member
abstract method abstract type
and you can implement it later by
reusing the same name
and that's what typically is used as the
primary form of abstractions
in object-oriented languages abstraction
name abstractions well object oriented
is not so popular here
so let me scratch that and call it
modular
it's even it's even a little bit
older the term than object oriented i
guess so modular came from the very
early 70s
because well that's basically what
happens in module and component systems
you have
connectors they have names and you deal
with these names you connect them
by name not by position by just saying
all these things
are parameters positions are too
limiting here in what you can do with
them
okay so once we have clarified that
let's look at the
types that we have in scala here so here
are essentially the
six most important parts of what we can
do with types how we can
form them so let me just see whether the
laser is step
strong oh yeah okay
so we can name a type uh we can use a
name type and that typically refers to a
class but not always
we can form a sort of intersection with
two types which we call a compound type
here
that means we have something which has
all the properties of a channel
and of a log thing so channel with
logged would have the properties of both
and we can refine types and that's
essentially the primary way to introduce
new bindings new names
so here we would say well we have a
channel and it has a closed method
of result type unit so here
you could say here that's the primary
way to introduce a name
here you refer to a name and then you
have a form of intersection
how you can build larger systems from
smaller one that's all very modular
that's stuff that you want to do with
components how you want to build your
systems
and then the the second half the
bottom half are types let's start with
the first one parameterize types
so list of strings that would be the
string here is a type parameter
of a parameterized type called list
then we have existential types that says
well what if
my type list i don't know what the
parameter is well
you can express it like this you say
list of t for some type t
and the logical foundation of that is
existential qualification
and you also have higher kind of types
which says well let me talk about just
the type constructor list without any
parameters so i say well
later on i will apply it to something so
that's
typical things that you would also find
in languages like haskell
that come from the functional world
so the first three are essentially
modular and the
second three are functional
and they're all orthogonal so here what
i really should have drawn is a
six-dimensional space of
uh type constructs because you can mix
any
two of them or any combination of them
in
in a type you can build uh uh
compositions of
parameterized existentials or whatever
so it's an orthogonal design
and you can pick here because i'm sort
of uh
forced to use just two dimensions i have
aligned them like this
you can pick the whole square here any
combinations of any of these types
that's particular to scala i think scala
tries to be very orthogonal so it tries
not to distinguish things too much
and be able to actually whatever
construct you have can be mixed with
any other construct in the language
more typical would be a design like this
so here what i pick is very roughly a
language let's say like oh camel or sml
where which has a type system and a
module system
so the modular part that's not ocamel
that's against scala but let's do the
thought experiment
what if we did the same thing split the
type system in the module system
then i guess you would find the
intersection the compound types
and the refinements on the modular side
but you would also need some
parameterization on the modular site if
you're
if you want to be powerful enough and
you would have the
functional abstractions on the
functional side here but of course you
will also need name types on the
functional side otherwise you can't get
anything off the ground
so what you get then in the end is a
language design space
which has more features so now here i
had eight features that i had to do
because i had
to re-implement generics twice and name
types twice
but fewer combinations because i'm not
as orthogonal
so when people sometimes say scala it's
so complicated because there are 27
different
ways to write a closure or something
like that you find all of that in the
internet
what they really need mean is it's that
because we have this high dimensional
space there are many possible
combinations of these things
but the combinations arise of very few
principles
whereas then people i'm interestingly i
typically much
happier with something like that where
they say well i have these
individual sub languages and we can't
combine them very well
but at least in each sub language
we have something that is easy to wrap
easier to wrap our head around
and there are fewer combinations than of
course
so we have this issue to say
orthogonality is good and well
but we have this problem of so many
combinations and
these combinations they are both
confusing for
people for the users because essentially
the design space is just
too too large here and they're also a
huge challenge for
compiler writer because all these
different features might have
bad feature interactions that you have
to deal with and they're just too many
possibles of them
to say well what happens if i have a
higher kind of existential in an
intersection
oops did we think of that when he wrote
the scala compiler
i'm not sure hopefully so what can we do
about that
i think the main idea here which i
would propose we consider is projections
so if we can
find that some of these elements
are essentially just combinations of
other elements in our design space
so we can reduce them to combinations of
other elements
then we have one in the complexity
argument for the compiler writer we have
one because we say well
compilation just means that we project
out
certain language features into others
and then we only have to deal
with this three-dimensional space here
at the bottom but not with the
six-dimensional space with all the
others
so what i propose here is that we
consider
that direction here and that's a bit
theoretical
because what i propose is actually to
compile away all the functional stuff
no more parameters no more existentials
no more higher kind of types
everything gets collapsed into the
module system here
intersections refinements and name types
if you look at a language like haskell
which is also very successful in that
regard
they went a little bit the other way so
essentially they collapse everything
into
the functional part their core language
is essentially system f
with essentially constraints and
witnesses which is what
type classes compile into
and type classes are sort of the haskell
equivalent of a module
system so that's one way to do it and
what we propose to do is actually go
exactly the other way
pick the modular part as the foundation
and the functional part as the derived
one
so how would that work well
before we say that is one thing we can
do
is here we cannot just reduce the
space internally that means that we say
certain language features can be
explained as others and therefore
wouldn't add to the
accidental feature interaction
complexity but we can also sometimes
remove the external representation the
surface syntax altogether
so what we can do here is actually
remove
parts of this and in scala i believe we
can remove
existentials altogether and a good part
of higher kind of types as well
so that we can get overall a much
smaller language footprint because we
could say then in this
new world uh existential types they are
not heavily used only used in quite
dubious circumstances
so if you need an existential type just
rewrite it in terms of its projection
we don't need to spend language syntax
and language complexity
on something like that so that leads me
to something i've been working on for
the last year or so
i've been working on a prototype
language exploration called dottie
and dottie is based on dot and dart is
called
is a calculus for dependent object types
so i get in a second to what that is and
dotty is a scalar-like language with
dot as its core that tries to really
take the dot
intuitions and also very concretely the
dot types and make that
the core types of a compiler that
compiles
essentially scala so dot
you find in a paper given at full
2012 full is the
workshop on foundations on object
oriented languages
and the calculus is here so for the rest
of the
uh my talk i will just present
concentrate on this slide
just well no maybe you if you're
interested in slide read the paper
what i will do is show you some of the
consequences this has for developers
the types in dottie now are if you look
at what we had in scala we still have
the name types
we have instead of these compound types
true intersections and actually also
true unions
i will explain later why we need that
and we have the refined type so we have
these type refinements where we can add
bindings to types
parameterized types as i've said we will
encode so we still have them in the
source syntax they're too useful not to
have them
but we can actually explain them all
away by just
refinements and name types and that's
precisely what's done internally in the
compiler so the compiler sees a
type parameterization and it immediately
desugars that to type members
and existential types and higher kind it
actually can be
cut completely
so how do how would we model generics
parameterized types
parameters like i said we can model as
abstract members
and arguments we can model as
refinements so we really make use of
this duality
which says we have functional parameters
object oriented
modular sorry abstract members and we
have
uh arguments that uh
pass an argument for a parameter whereas
a refinement
instantiates an abstract member so let's
do let's look first at the class
definition
we have class set here and
it has a parameter t set of t so
internally that would be represented as
something like that class set
and it has a type member and here i
wrote a dollar because i
i don't really want to this to conflict
with any
name t that it inherits from another
class or things like that so it's a
manual it's a compiler made up name here
that i use here for the member
okay what about an application
of this type constructor to an argument
set of string well that would simply be
the refinement
which says the uh set here
uh is we have a set i wonder why the
it doesn't work anymore oh yeah we have
a set
and it's type member dollar t is now
string
that's a refinement of this set here so
that gets rid of those two
parameterization things so what's the
hardest part of generics
what in your expression in your
experience so i believe
for most people the hardest part of
generics really is variance
when generics clash with subtyping
that's when that's what's typically hard
to get your head around
so you have solutions like in in java
the wildcards with uh
question mark extends super type
question mark
super subtype these sort of things it's
very hard to get that and
in scala we have essentially plus t and
minus t as the type parameters so let's
have a look at that how would that be
compiled away
and in fact it would be compiled away
pretty similar to what you've seen
before
so here we have a covariant type we have
we say list is covariant
list of lists of employees are in fact a
list of people and what we would do is
the translation is exactly the same as
before
but when we have a type argument for
such a type list of string then
we would say that translates into list
of type dollar t
is upper bounded by string so it's an
unknown subtype of string it isn't equal
to string
well why is that well because if
somebody gave you a list of
people then it could actually have been
a list of employees we just said it's a
subtype a list of employees can be
substituted for a list of people so that
means that if we want to find out
for such a list what is the type of its
uh
members here then we can't know that it
is in fact string here
or m or m uh or people
it could also be a subtype of that so
that's the translation
that we do here and in fact that
translation has been known for a while
uh i think it's uh was question cup toro
professors wrote a paper about that end
of the nineties uh
kristen kaptob is now the organizer of
the go to conferences
um so uh but i don't think there's any
language
yet that actually exploits this uh
in the core language design and that's
what i'm proposing here
okay here's a variation of that
that actually increases the power for
the programmer
we said first that the types here they
were mangled
so we set the parameter t
here became the type parameter dollar t
and that's a mangled name so you can't
access it
that means to do anything with that
you're forced to use the
parameter syntax what we actually could
do and i think it's actually worthwhile
doing that
is making the names optionally available
and the syntax i propose for that is
just to write type the keyword type in
front of the parameter
and in that case you should pick a a
good name
not just t but a name that signifies
something like lm
so we have sets of alums and elements
are now visible and
the only change here that i propose is
to say well in that case alan would
actually be clear text it would be a
type member that he can access
and that type member
has is accessible as both a parameter
and as a refined type
and the same thing here for the
covariant thing that's completely
analogous actually to what we have with
well parameters in scala
where we can write this well field here
for the class and that what that means
is that the
fld thing is not just a parameter to the
class it is retained as an
accessible field for in the class itself
the idea with the type is except to do
exactly the same thing
for types
so that's that's our design
what about getting the things we got rid
of existentials and higher kind of types
so let's have a look at existentials
what's the type of a list with an
arbitrary element type we don't know
what the element type is
so previously we would use this syntax
for it list of
underscore which is in in corresponds to
the java syntax list of
angle brackets question marks so that's
a wild card
uh and uh in scala it actually expands
into an existential type
this is the first thing you saw is just
a shorthand for the existential type
where we say it's a list of t
for some type t we don't know what the
type is
so what how would we express that now
well we would be just list
list is good enough list has an abstract
member of a type
we don't need to specify what it is so
if we don't well that means we don't
know what the specification is
so we don't need to have any special con
construct for
existentials so what about higher kind
it
so what is the type of list constructors
then
by that when applied to an element give
you a list of that element type
so previously that was the type list and
i propose
it will stay the type list so the type
list is fine
and we can always instantiate this type
later
without any added magic or complications
of higher kind of types because what you
can write here
is you can say well let's make a type
alias say x equals list
and then we could write later x where
type t equals string
or type lm equals string or use the
parameterized version x of string
because we know from the type x that it
has
a member element or t whatever we named
it and that element can be instantiated
with
a refinement or its source center
surface syntax
parameterization
so the weird thing in the system
existential types and higher kind of
types are actually the same they're both
called lists
and in fact both are really nothing
special they're just types of abstract
members
so essentially they they are the same
but this
at the same time they cease to exist and
the the
core of that is that in fact we do not
distinguish in this type system
between types and type constructors
you could say well aren't we giving up
type safety when we do that
after all it's very useful to be able to
make that distinction
well maybe but i believe it's actually
the right trade-off here because
the point is this sort of kind
correctness that we say a type is not a
type constructor
that's something that sort of
you can use to be sure of the type of
a library independently of its
application
but even if you don't make this
distinction you will always catch out
any type errors
when you type check a whole program so
you will get the type errors anyway
in this system you might get them
sometimes a little bit later
in some circumstances that i believe i
will actually be rather rare
so i think it's the right trade-off
so what about the horrible type error
message that i've given you
before well that was because in scala
the least upper bounds of two types can
be
infinitely large it doesn't really exist
in the language
and i believe we can actually fix that
as well by having native
union and intersection types which will
be written
and and or and that can actually
address this problem at the root so you
would just get a type error message that
you
it found an iterable of x or an iterable
of y
and it's not compatible with uh some
other type rather than trying to
combine the compute the union of
iterable of x and iterable of y
which led to this explosion of types
so you might ask well cool will this be
scala what what is the
use of this language here so that for
the moment it's still an experiment
so i've been working on that for a while
and
my hope is that yes it will be scala it
depends on how
compatible we can make it so what the
the aim is to make this really for all
intents of purposes
compatibly enough that we can migrate
most programs automatically
into this uh this type system an
important note here is there's a foscada
people sip 18 that's the one that forces
you to declare imports when you want to
use higher kind of types and
existentials
that's actually very useful here because
it actually means that you will
you're already now forced to flag usages
of higher kind of types or existentials
that might be a problem in this
translation so if your program
uh is compiled without any language
feature imports for higher kind it and
and existentials then you should be okay
so to conclude i think the essence of
scala
that i try to bring out here is that we
really want to harness the power of
naming
to say names bindings and
refinements are the core of what really
the type system is
and that's a bit theoretical because
most type systems actually go
into the direction to say predicate
calculus is what type systems are
and uh these the predicate calculus is
essentially
the functional column so that's sort of
the core and we
in scala actually we want to turn things
around and say the
the intersections and refinements and
and names are the core of what it is
and i believe the other thing that i try
to express here is that really
what i try to achieve is that i want to
get out
a simple language that gives you this
abstraction here
i know that scada has been criticized
for being very complex rightly or
wrongly so and what i will
try to do here is really address the
things that really are
probably problems the feature
interactions of too many type
constructors
and trying to really get a simple type
system here and that's
in to a large degree new ground i don't
think we have done
a lot of that before so types i believe
are trouble
tooling is much harder for them error
messages oh my god
the conceptual complexity of types
ways down languages and certainly true
that to design a good typed
language that probably needs is a
multi-person effort for a decade
to design a good dynamically typed
language is
generally much easier so you can iterate
faster
get to good solutions faster than the
types types are burdened
burdensome for these things and of
course types are also
give you scope for misuse so the problem
with imposing constraints is that some
your co-workers might use these
constraints in ways you don't agree
with but i believe that despite all
these problems
types are worth it because they can be
the language that leads us to great
designs
thank you